hello is de nada and Finn Kennedy from
Sussex in England and my question where
the james webb space telescope is to
what extent do you hope that will
improve the quality of information
regarding the search for extra solar
system planets and what might that tell
us from what i understand the telescope
is it truly astonishing feat of
engineering well done indeed thank you
so mr. Kennedy wants to know about the
James Webb Space Telescope and what it
will tell us about planets around other
stars so James Webb telescope is a good
tool for following up on discoveries
that are made with other tools and it's
also very good for taking pictures of
planets that might be there we already
know from the Hubble Space Telescope
that a good telescope in space can
actually take a picture that'll show a
planet so it'll only work for a bright
planet that's pretty far from its star
so jupiter-like planets are good
candidates especially if they're young
and hot the other tool that we have is
what's called transit spectroscopy once
in a while a planet will go between its
star and our telescope and it will block
some of the Starlight and some of that
starlight will actually go through the
atmosphere of that planet so we can tell
something about the characteristics of
that planet from what we see when this
happens so we will have a catalog of
stars where we know when the these
transits are going to occur we can turn
our telescope in that direction and take
the data and see something about the
chemistry of those planets it will be
very exciting time